commençons par vous et ses propos de
tokyo est ce que vous diriez ce matin
que votre détermination est totale non
seulement pour les primaires n'est pour
la candidature en 2017
j'étais un peu violent comme les skis
ont dansé dans cette lettre il commet
détermination soit totale je vais pas le
répéter tous les matins pourquoi est-ce
que je suis déterminé c'est pas ce pas
une question personnelle c'est parce que
je suis convaincu que la france est en
face d'un risque déclin considérable que
j'ai occupé un certain nombre de
responsabilités au gouvernement et la
dernière à la tête du gouvernement et
que je vois comment on peut organiser le
sursaut à la fois de la france de la
nation française et de l'europe pour
éviter un déclin qui aujourd'hui me
paraît inéluctable
bon je suis sans doute pas tout seul à
porter ce projet mais il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui dans les circonstances
politiques qui sont celles de notre pays
je n'entends personne d'autre tenir le
discours que je tiens c'est à dire on
n'est pas dans une situation normale
on n'est pas dans une échéance politique
au moment là connu tellement depuis
trente ans on est devant une question
est ce que dans 20 ans il y aura encore
une nation française est sale race par
une érection et sa part à une
clarification à droite c'est un cadre à
leurs besoins et ces corpus idéologique
et d'un chef c'est c'est la raison pour
laquelle je me suis battu pour que le
candidat qui va porter les valeurs dans
la droite et du centre soit choisi dans
le cadre d'une élection primaire